kaffee ein absolutes genuss thema
welches auf einem kanal noch gar nicht
stattgefunden hat ihr wisst aber ich
liebe kaffee also ich habe keine
gelegenheit ausgelassen um zu sagen dass
ich es sehr sehr gerne mag kaffee zu
machen ich habe aber noch nie ein ganzes
video über kaffee gemacht heute ist der
tag dafür endlich gekommen ich freue
mich sehr es ist ein wirklicher traum
von mir ich wollte wirklich schon immer
mal einen tag im café als barista
arbeiten und nachdem das video in dem
ich einen tag in der sterneküche
gearbeitet habe euch so gut gefallen hat
habe ich mir gedacht ich mache das
vielleicht noch ein zwei weitere
lokalitäten heute im café number five
und köln am barbarossaplatz bin sehr
gespannt was mich erwarten wird ich
werde ganz ganz viel kaffee machen ich
werde hoffentlich viel lernen und ich
bin gespannt was sie vom tag mitnehmen
kann deshalb kommen mit in die welt des
kaffees und ich verspreche euch auch
wenn ich keinen kaffee trinken ist es
unfassbar interessant wieviel man lernen
kann und wie komplex dieses thema ist
aber die schuld
ich sitze jetzt mit john und dann macht
das marketing kompakt und mirja passform
mit wir heute was ist meine aufgabe ja
genau also heute ist er max er nicht bei
uns herr der kaffeemaschine er will sich
heute machen allem auszuwählen was wir
so einen kaffee anbieten wir sind schon
ganz gespannt brauchen als max
hereingekommen es war der blick
beeindruckt von der kaffeemaschine wir
stehen haben also ich freue mich auf
jeden fall schon drauf auf dem preschen
und auf den geschmack wie du uns ins
herz haben und dass wir dort über ein
cooler tagen und hoffentlich bist du
auch mal so leicht so eine stressige
situation geraten mal gucken und mit den
achsen aus dem konzept
okay ich bin selbst sehr gespannt ich
habe mir eine sache überlegt eine sache
vorgenommen ich möchte heute einen
schwarm in die latte weil ich habe schon
so ein herz kann ich ein bisschen fahren
kann ich ein bisschen und steuern wollte
heute unbedingt schon immer mal machen
aber das ding ist um das zu können musst
du 108 machen natürlich mal 100 cafés
umliegenden gratis einen kompletten
koffein shop hat mein ziel für heute ist
wenn ich das schaffe dann kann ich mir
den barista stempel geben welchen
aufgeregt war ich ganz viel kaffee zu
machen und ich würde sagen gelegen los
[Musik]
das ist dein reich eigentlich und
übergibt es mir heute genau denn sehr
gespannt und das schöne maschine muss
sich schon feststellen also dass das
überhaupt mit sondermaschinen mehr
arbeiten darf unglaublich kannst mir
nochmal oder auch nur zuschauen kurzen
brander und geben was ist der prozess
bei einem kapieren einfach wir sind sie
träger schlagen daraus würden mit dem
reinigen damit halt die restliche
kaffeesatz von der folgen ladung aus ist
dann um das war in dem fall ziehen wir
einen doppelten ja einfach nur noch
liebe wahrscheinlich nur noch ja wir
arbeiten nur mit doppel 7 und einfachen
ja dann in der zeit flaschen wer einmal
damit der restlichen besatzer bauernhaus
ist ja dann müssten wir einmal die
gemeinen café festdrücken schauen dass
man immer gerade ist träger wieder heim
nebel ich fühle mich auch gerade so wie
in der schule wenn man so ein thema
schon vorher zu hause behandelt hat und
weiß schon alles so einfach freiwillig
erklärt das super verständlich ich mache
da immer so vertraut draußen ist sehr
gut so versteht sich dabei wir bis jetzt
keine schüler von selbst stoppen nein
man hat hier oben auch wenn an zeichnet
sie sollte auch immer zwischen 28 und 32
kollegen okay man hört das ist jetzt in
dem fall wollte ist ja ein kopfkino
machen wir jetzt noch in essen gezogen
haben machen wir uns nicht länger aus
genau bedeutet war es die breitesten
cappuccino mit der
[Musik]
presseseite weil wir auch claus garbe
den schock nach ob das auch schon direkt
so eine optimierungs geschichte die man
wahrscheinlich dann über die zeit für
sich so herausgefunden hat oder das ist
dann wie so fabrik fließbandarbeit wenn
man versucht von links der rechtsweg zu
arbeiten oder wenn es um dann irgendwann
werde von rechts erlegen
am einfachsten ist genauso wie mit dem
klub mit ihrem haus mit
ja ja dann dieses wirksam einfach
schwierig das von unten zu greifen denn
einmal schwenken einmal zu viel zu
schwenken
dass die creme halt aufbricht und dass
man unter die crema kommt mit der milch
glaube ich habe alles verstanden ich
habe mir vorgenommen ich möchte heute in
spanien macht ja dann wieder voll ist
ambitioniert ja auch lange tages lagen
aber sichtlich viel spaß danke dass du
da bist vielen dank für die einweisung
ich kann sagen ich bin jetzt andere nach
kafka und ich warte jetzt mal auf
bestellung würde zu sagen wow dann ging
es also los der erste kaffee des tages
ihr müsst euch vorstellen ich habe dann
im vergleich gebracht diese maschine ist
ein bugatti nicht nur preislich sondern
stellt euch vor ihr fahrt normalerweise
150 ps und dann sitzt hier plötzlich in
seinem 1600 ps bugatti schira das habe
ich mir gedacht als ich die dampfwalze
eingestellt habe
mama mir die maschine hat so viel power
gefühlt ist mir das alles um die ohren
geflogen so ich habe zu hause und 150 ps
kaffeemaschine die wirklich schon sehr
gut ist und das ding hat so viel power
dass ich gedacht hatte scheiße kann so
dass überhaupt bedienen dann mussten
aber erklärt ich kann diesen hebel
runterstellen alles ein bisschen
entspannter hat aber trotzdem ist alles
irgendwie ganz ganz anders als zu hause
und ich musste mich wirklich erstmal
einarbeiten und mein großes ziel vom
schwanen in der latte art ist erst noch
ein bisschen nach hinten gerutscht
nächste bestellung ein amerikaner sich
sehr herzlich amerikaner basiert wie
jedes andere kaffee getränke aus der
italienischen kaffeeküche kommt haben es
breche
italienischen schwarzen kappe wenn man
so darüber nach wegen das heißt schon
amerikaner für die amerikaner in italien
schwarze karte bestellt haben weil der
täter kam jetzt machen wollten und es
ist dann quasi ein espresso verlängert
mit heißem wasser also der espresso ist
immer die fast immer war es egal ob so
latte macchiato und cappuccino espresso
macchiato zimmer und ein espresso
gefühlig amerikaner österreich
gegen extrem an artikeln und natürlich
das thema ist jetzt ein bisschen
schneller zersetzt zeit tritt aus
reflexiv sauber gemacht aber mein bestes
jahr ihr eigentlich ihr drin weil sie
die ganze zeit geweckt denn ihre
versuche
[Musik]
ich muss wirklich sagen ich hab so ein
bisschen stressiger vorgestellt also es
war so ein richtig entspannter tag die
jungs meinen auch zu mir so das ist
jetzt heute kein sonntag ein samstag wo
du die ganze zeit durch gegen kaffee
macht sondern man konnte wirklich ein
bisschen runterkommen und die tätigkeit
das café machen hat mir auch in diesem
größeren volumen richtig viel spaß
gemacht also ich sehe mich da wirklich
ich glaube das wäre eine sache die ich
machen würde wenn ich nicht diese videos
machen würde wo kann ich noch mehr
gespart habe aber ich sehe ich wirklich
ist so ein café ich habe echt überlegt
aber die jungs fragen seid ihr euch noch
mal vorbeikommen kann weil man wird mit
jedem mal besser und dieser kleine aber
feine fortschritt macht richtig viel
spaß gerade wenn man so ein bisschen
ärger thema
ich habe um box noch irgendwas so als
aufgabe gemacht es zu stellen sollen wir
denn noch mal so ein bisschen catchen du
musst ja auch quasi die qualität auch
mal überhaupt prüfen ob das richtig
verstehe was meinen sie durch das ja so
langsam die sonne raus dann hätte ich
jetzt eigentlich schon bock auch so ein
eis aber cappuccino ich meine
ja erlaubt dass ein leichtes sogar für
ja ich hab da zum ende seiner durch das
solange die sonne bisschen raus kommt
hier schon sehr bock aus und heißt
cappuccino im hafen
kino am 11
ja es stimmt
die bestehenden trend bedienen wir den
flugplatz bestellt meine freundin auch
hier
wirkt das nicht so ganz sicher was er
macht
wir beurteilen denn jetzt einfach mal
dass max franke natürlich sei der
verlauf ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz
so viel aber mit aber trotzdem decker
[Musik]
ist wirklich leid aber das ist 6.10
verheerende bewertung zu meinem weg zu
meiner beurteilung muss man mal sagen
hatte max wohl die info nicht das ist
ein doppeltes besser sein muss werde er
mit den doppeln das beste gemacht worden
dann wäre ich mehr als zufrieden und
verwies dann bin ich noch aber danke
dann auch gefallen dass ich doch besser
noch einmal nachgefragt hätte weil für
mich selbst dass so ein ding mit einem
espresso schoss aber natürlich die
kunden die immer wieder kommen sind
daran gewöhnt wie macht es das café und
klar doch wieder ist das hat natürlich
mehr power haben wir zwar auch noch den
kaffee
geht auf meine kappe also dann auch noch
der job ganz heute eingeladen hat leider
nicht ganz zufrieden wollen ist es so
weit ich habe jetzt ein paar kaffee ist
gemacht bin ein bisschen eingebucht ich
würde sagen ich mache jetzt meine story
und dann komm paar von euch vorbei und
ich kann für euch gemacht ja okay leute
stories draußen ziemlich spannend wer
vorbeikommt ob überhaupt jemand kommt
was gibt es hier wieder einen
arbeitsplatz machen sollte sie musste
arbeiten
so ich habe hier eine wunderschöne kunde
noch die ein kriterium stellen möchte
was hättest du denn gern live platte mit
hafer mails oder erklärte
probieren
marie hat mir einen kleinen snack hier
mal mit verletzten kommuniziert dass ich
einmal ein partner freie stellen habe
nämlich doro wir haben alles das hier
ist jetzt ein protein regel der lustige
reise max heißt und jeder heißt du dich
nicht 64 sondern auch
hochleistungssportler besser wird immer
proteinriegel zudem ist ein schwarz ich
finde die sind aber wirklich übertrieben
lecker ich habe davon auch wieder so ein
ganz großes paket bestellt da gehen die
kosten runter und das so ein bisschen
das ding bei coromant man kann von allem
große portionen große pakete stellen
weniger verpackung politik dass ihr
kennt den schnee vom letzten mal aber
ich probiere mal
wenn ich mal wieder einen tag hinter dem
tresen arbeite ist das wirklich sehr
sehr willig zwischenmahlzeit man kann
nicht mehr was einst merken sagt nun
ganz ganz viele andere sachen gibt's bei
corus fair produziert super
qualitätscheck das gern mal mit dem kot
5 max fünf dicke darauf fünf prozent
rabatt natürlich nicht noch das sondern
auch alle möglichen anderen sachen ich
glaube du musst wieder an die arbeit
jetzt die ersten die wegen der story
gekommen
sehr gut von 1 bis 10 eine art sagst du
ja damals einen kopfhörer platte sie
wollten was besonderes ich find das
besondere und der stoff mit bis zu
200 blatt
als echter hammer ist coop sr und wirst
ich jetzt sagen 1 von 10
ich kann es auch leider noch ein paar
von euch auf einen kaffee einladen zu
können ich habe ja die story gemacht und
ein paar sind vorbeigekommen kaffee
ausgegeben bisschen gequatscht so das
fand ich sehr schön auch mal so
gesichter hinter den zahlen kennen zu
lernen so ein bisschen und wer weiß
vielleicht können wir in zukunft ja auch
das ganze mal mit einem burger machen
mit einer pizza machen mit einem döner
machen wenn ich nochmal die
verschiedensten bereiche der gastronomie
auf decke mit diesem format ich habe auf
jeden fall große lust darauf weil das
sind auch so wertvolle einblicke für
mich so das ist eine geile story zu
sagen ich habe mal einen tag im café
gearbeitet
also so werde ich das auch gar keinen
fall hin bekommen aber es ist einfach
wunderschön aus einem guss ohne einmal
abzusetzen play shops ist nicht heute
aber vielleicht schafft es im laufe
seines lebens wie sie wirklich so frech
leicht aus eigentlich was ist so
schwierig
nein zu schnell geschüttet das macht
keinen sinn red ist macht wenigstens ein
halbwegs märz es gibt auch allerletzter
versuche ich probiere es noch einmal ein
schwan ich sage ehrlich ich sehe keine
guten chancen ich dachte ich ich wäre
sicherer
[Musik]
coach klopp das sieht jetzt absolut
scheiße aus aber von der bewegung her
was kann also ihr könnt selbst
entscheiden könnt ihr hier drinnen
schwan erkennen oder nicht ich gebe dir
jetzt den wartenden kunden werde jetzt
ganz ganz toll probieren schwarz machen
zu hause sehen wir uns wieder würde ich
sagen jetzt ein
was soll ich sagen vielen dank fürs
zuschauen es war eine große freude ich
werde wirklich noch mal hingehen und
kaffee machen also ich meine es todernst
ihr könnt ja meine kommentare schreiben
welche bereiche der gastronomie ich noch
erleben soll ich glaube da wirklich noch
einiges an meine grenzen bringt danke
fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal
läuft's gut und scharf